3Hey, this is my bottom card collection Come on, it's
amazing Event limited Ro Hatake Kakashi Wheels are in mode Hey, almost everything goes through this, isn't
it?  How
come I don't have the 7th Hokage card Why can't I get the card I want?
It's something like that, so
it's the first time I've seen something,
so I'll give it to you Yokoi
Are you saying that you know what this looks like?
I can put it in, so can
you teach me ninjutsu instead
?
No matter how hard it is to get what I really want, I'm passionate about getting it on my own
.
Sooner or later
Niisato is free
and the smell of Tease's navel Training is tough go-go
[music]
All right, here's a sweet key that's hard
to beat I'll just give you Kira